Elementor 116 was named at the same time
as element 114 116 has the name
livermorium after the Lawrence Livermore
Lab in the United States is quite
surprising than element discovered in
Russia should be given a name after a
town or a lab in the United States but
there's a really good reason as you've
probably seen as demonstrating several
times already that you make super-heavy
elements by taking the nucleus of a
heavy element and the nucleus of a
lighter one and banging them together
and eventually they stick so you have
the lighter one incorporated in the
nucleus of the heavy one and in the case
of element 116 the light element was
calcium which is element number 20 so
the heavy one has to be element number
96 and 96 is one of the transuranium
synthetic elements curium named after
madame curie it is an element that does
not occur naturally but it differs from
elements like 116 where only a few atoms
have been made because you can make a
small lump of curium not you can't make
tons of it but you can make some of it
they're made in nuclear reactors by
bombardment of one element after another
I think it's probably made by Neutron
bombardment of plutonium and then a lot
of purification and in this particular
case the curium for the experiment was
made in America and flown to Russia
where they did the experiment so it
really was international collaboration
and therefore in honor of this the
Russian and US teams who combined
together decided to call it livermorium
that seems very generous to me professor
that that feels like someone winning
car race and then sharing the trophy
with the person that fueled up their car
no it's like somebody winning a car race
and sharing a prize with a car designer
so without the curiam there'd be no
element 116 so I think it's quite fair
what's more it all knows the lab rather
than the name of the person as I
mentioned in the earlier video the
Lawrence Livermore Lab was originally an
atomic weapons laboratory founded at the
height of the Cold War
when Russia and the United States were
almost at war and were enemies and
therefore this is really a very good
symbol of peace nobody knows what the
chemistry of element 116 would be like
it will be like the chemistry of
polonium and polonium itself is a highly
radioactive element so chemists like me
don't really know much about the
chemistry of polonium I suspect that as
most elements are metallic at the bottom
of the periodic table that element 116
if you could get another atoms all
together at the same time would also be
metallic but like the other elements at
this part of the periodic table the real
importance of element 116 is to study
how it decays and for physicists to
understand the forces that hold together
these really large nuclei in some ways I
think it is easier to understand these
forces than with the more conventional
elements like sodium where everything is
held so tightly that you can't easily
watch them decay when you talk about
this do you feel you're talking
chemistry are talking physics I suppose
in some ways I'm talking physics but I'm
a chemist so I'm not sure if chemists
can talk physics and it is part of our
periodic table and by our I don't mean
chemists but I mean everybody's periodic
table and even chemists need to know how
these elements are synthesized and why
they're important can I ask you a
question would you rather have an
element named after you or win a Nobel
Prize
well I think that's that's a very
interesting question and probably
completely theoretical and I'm not
really at erudition however I think it
would be a bit unfair to have an element
named after oneself if you hadn't
actually done some work towards it I'm a
Seaborg discovered elements
Meitner all these other people and
Copernicus didn't elements hadn't been
discovered but he was a great scientist
anyway but in general I think if it is
going to be a name of a modern scientist
it has to be the name of somebody that's
made a real contribution to this area of
science just like I would feel a
complete fraud if somebody named a
mountain after me unless I claim being
the first person to climb to the top and
he is one final little fact that even
the professor didn't know when we were
making this video and that is that
Livermore in California was actually
formally known as Nottingham and of
course for those of you who don't know
will see the logos at the end of all
their videos our films are actually
based at the School of Chemistry at the
University of Nottingham so who knows
maybe if they'd stuck with that original
name the lab would have been called the
Lawrence Nottingham labs and we'd be
making a video today about Nottingham
making it onto the periodic table but of
course that didn't happen and we've got
livermorium